what do you think your mother would have
thought of Megan is the circus days from
fashion to their Hollywood connections
there's undoubtedly a lot Megan Marco
and the leap Princess Diana would have
bonded over including the fact that died
was the og royal rebel now we're
breaking down all the ways she paved the
way for her youngest son Prince Harry
and his wife my mother Princess Diana
was a role model to so many without
realising the impact she hoped she would
have on so many lives
for starters Diana was the first royal
bride to have a job before her 1981
wedding to Prince Charles he shot me
down he said will you marry me I thought
the whole thing was hysterical getting
married it was so grown-up and he was
Diana kindergarten teacher and hope and
we all know Megan with a working gal
before tying the knot with Prince Harry
from her days on Deal or No Deal to
starring in suits Megan is quite the
Hollywood resume I'm Rachel Zane I'll be
giving your orientation take notes I'm
not gonna repeat myself well as megan
has Diana to thank for being a force for
change in her mother-in-law Queen
Elizabeth life I think that she might
well be the first royal fiancee to be
invited to Sandringham for Christmas the
Queen has really gone above and beyond
and she's done that very simply to make
Megan feel welcome and to keep Harry
happy according to one report the leap
princess is responsible for schooling
the palates on the importance of
allowing royal wives to keep strong
relationships with their families and
old friends this is probably the reason
you've seen Megan's mom Doria Ragland so
involved with Megan in Harry's wedding
and now their newborn son Archie
which brings us to Diana's
non-traditional parenting style she made
the decision that no matter what despite
all of the difficulties of growing up in
that limelight and on that stage she was
going to ensure that both of us had as
normal life as possible something the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex have tried to
mirror the coupler determined for Archie
to have as normal
life as possible to Frogmore they have
essentially built a fortress their
sanctuary where they're going to raise
their child away from the spotlight arch
he is being raised in a very loving
relatively ordinary upbringing as as far
as royal childhoods are concerned they
really want him to experience an
ordinary childhood Plus unlike Diana's
marriage and a lot of the ones before
her she's encouraged her boys to marry
for love and it seems they both followed
suit what do you think how your mother
would feel about this family I was just
looking down you know with with tears in
our eyes being incredibly proud of what
we what we've you know established I
suppose I think everything about Harry's
thoughtfulness and the inclusion of that
and obviously not being able to meet his
mom it's so important to me to to know
that she's a part of this with us